kitty kat kommen zu kriegst du oft ist
sie gewünscht worden und diese wünsche
sind jetzt endlich in erfüllung gegangen
und sie haben auch lange mit der
plattenfirma verhandelt und das beste
ist das album kommt sogar früher aus als
geplant pink mafia darüber werden wir
reden und natürlich über noch viel mehr
und vor allem über eure nutzer fall
irgendwie kommt mir den text bekannt wo
ich muss ihnen schon mal irgendwann
gesagt haben also seid möglichst kreativ
denn die besten kommen dran am besten
als video frage hochladen und den info
text lesen dann kann eigentlich nichts
mehr schief gehen ich drücke die daumen